okay hi everyone
this is a language design
review meeting incremental language
design and we are looking at a variety
of
new
uh potential features for language
all right i'm told i need to run the
prototype build for the first thing here
so did you implement splice for the head
yep
does it seem to be sensible
um
yes
i mean it's
we need to
use this
that's not a good sign
um
why is the spinning well i mean this is
the x-cone also who knows
uh okay so what you're saying is that
i can say f of a b splice
what is it splice list cd or fcd
it's list i was thinking about f but i
thought that
we could give an opportunity to have to
evaluate
and we don't want that
i see
good point
yes that's a good point and if this is
supposed to be kind of a sequence you
know a nice nicer version of sequence
than it should be a list
fine yeah i think a list is a more
flexible thing
so let's see so
i think this is just going to be useful
thing i don't really know what um
i assume that we don't want the function
to be first
anybody got an opinion about that
i prefer it second because it keeps the
same position for a list
what do you mean
one arc form
yeah okay fine
uh this seems fine i mean is there are
there any other holding issues
i mean so the one question would be one
could imagine
a a third argument to splice which is a
processing function so let's say it was
hold of i don't know
i'm not sure whether this makes any
sense i'm just asking this let's say
it's f says what you splice into and
then the third thing will be an action
function to apply at the time of
splicing
do you mean hold of a splice rather than
splice of hold
i didn't mean hold of a splice i meant i
meant
that you're holding this thing
and then this action here would be for
example release hold
and that what would happen is
that
upon
insertion
this would apply the function this
action function
to the payload
before the splice through the payload or
to the whole
uh
i mean i think
right because you can just apply it to
the payload
how right there
no but how do you oh you mean does it
make it doesn't make a difference
yeah or
i see so you're saying that what i could
do is f
a b release hold but doesn't the release
hold
no no i i more mean just that that you
know you might as well what's the point
of of holding c and d if you're just
going to release hold it before you put
it into the f
presumably what you want to do is you
want to put it into the f
you know in held form and you want f you
know if f is a hold all function you
want f of a b c d
right where c and d don't i mean that
that's your end you know but if you
apply release hold to c and d before it
gets inserted into the f then they're
just going to be evaluated yeah okay
fair enough
well does this seem all useful to go
ahead
well i was going to ask you a quick
implementation question which is i mean
so is this implemented with with like up
values basically yes or yes like nothing
okay yeah but i guess
so i guess then the only question would
be if there are any
um
like
if there are any places where sequence
hold is used where this might
mess with it
i guess this is a lot safer than
sequence so maybe it's maybe there's no
need for a sequence hold like concept
but uh
yeah well we're worth looking at places
where sequence hold
is used because this would be a good
replacement
i mean let's see in the documentation
so you mean that if we put set for
example in the second argument
something like that
is set sequence hold
um
yeah
yes it is because you can say x equals a
sequence
which is horrifying uh yes yes right
and this is a much better alternative
yeah i don't see a big i mean
yeah right i i think this thing is inert
enough that if you you know if you put
set in the second argument you kind of
know what you're doing
okay here's a question uh what
is this thing a pattern or is this thing
a literal
presumably it should allow a pattern
it should allow f or g and so on
i see right now it's a literal but
we can make it a
seems nice if it's a pattern
if it can be done efficiently i mean
clearly the literal case should be the
most efficient but i mean i could
imagine this being
uh i mean
in
things i'm doing at least there's a lot
more composite head headdress type
activity than we've ever had before and
it i can well imagine
matching on some kind of elaborate head
but if the elaborate head is an
alternative's expression
it gets messed up right
what do you mean good point
if the head of the thing you're splicing
into is
alternatives fg
well no you're you use verbatim or
something yeah yeah you'd have to use
verbatim right yeah it's a passion i
mean it's a pattern so whatever it you
know it's going to do the pattern
matching thing and i think that's fair i
mean it's like if you you know if you're
applying this to an expression that has
weird pattern you know sort of pattern
uh
pattern symbols in it then you know
sure you might get some slightly weird
behavior
right right we've had we solved that
problem with verbatim all over the place
we just stack you in it and it's people
understand it it's fine
i just want to admire this isn't this
lovely
yep
it's going to be really useful
just this unbelievable amounts of code
i've written that has ridiculous uh you
know
maps and things that is now unnecessary
do you know if the um if if uh it's now
like vectorized in any way
or is it is it still similar efficiency
to
to map
i don't know i don't know you could
i i was going to say that i know rob was
trying to make it more efficient for the
pact cases and things like that but i
don't know the status of them
but this is
actually certainly already it's very
nice but i think if it's vectorized too
then it will be
super mega nice
well so but ask rob i mean
yeah he's certainly aware of those
issues
yes
there are some examples just in case uh
the only thing i was thinking about is
when the head is is a whole head so
you're talking about splice yes
okay where do i go for the examples uh
open this uh section
oh under gosh
why was i not paying attention to that
okay
oh yeah in particular if it's hold
complete right because that will stop
but actually i guess hold will stop the
values too right so
yes
so that's important for example for
association so
so right now nothing is not
uh doing anything in association so this
is going to be the same
sorry held expressions
yes there
so
that's fine though that's very nice what
that's doing seems to me
right so it has to be at that level so
of course
if if hold was hold of a list
then yeah
sorry how how does that work i mean if
it was hold complete would it not work
or like i mean how is the up value
working when it's inside of a hole you
can use up values in a holding function
just not hold all complete
okay
so let's see it so if we hold complete
though it'll it'll i mean i think that's
okay that's
such as the life
why didn't that work
that's the case that's too deep
so the list is never evaluated and so we
never see that it's a splice there
i see but if that was actually a hold
itself
exactly
then it would work that's not a
particularly useful case
list
right if you remove the list and you
have hold then it does work
i have hold in the splice exactly
but now one last case to try is to do
that again but with hold complete
and then i guess here it's not going to
splice it in
right
that's life
i think that's desired though
yeah right i agree hold complete that's
what you wanted to do
all right mixed cases do i need to read
these what are these are these no this
is just showing that
depending on the head you have
one or the other splices
oh i see
nice
um all right any more to say about this
what was the thing you said about
nothing not working in associations
so if you say
a goes to b
x goes to nothing
that means you don't expect that to do
anything yeah i believe it does do
something if you do a goes to b comma
nothing then i think that nothing does
go away
i thought
really i thought it would just be an
error in the association
wow
how would i put it in there though
how would i get it in there other than
me it's it's it's usually pretty i i
found that nothing in associations like
i haven't really used it much because
again yeah i mean normally you know you
can't like map over the association and
then replace things with nothing and
have the keys disappear right so
it's
yeah
it's pretty contrived when you can
actually use it
why would it not behave this way
well because i'm just surprised that
anything sort of
naked at the top level of an association
doesn't just cause a spew of error
messages
it may be a fluke because something goes
through an intermediate state of a list
it's just that i mean the so-called
central dogma would have nothing
disappearing just like it does in list
wouldn't it
only if it wasn't
well that
that that's different
i meant i meant the case where it's
naked there why does the central dogma
have anything to say about the naked
case
well just because the central dogma i
believe says it's supposed to behave
like it was in a list
well like the values were in the list
but there's no values it's just a
nothing
exactly
but that is why i think that in the
first case the essential dogma is
violated a little bit because nothing
stays
[Music]
yes i mean there will be an argument for
this disappearing in this case i'm not
sure that the central dogma
really well i don't know if it's ever
been stated formally but i'm not sure it
really means that only the values behave
like they're in a list
all right but look at your point that
this isn't a value yeah right
i think we let's not cross i don't think
there's only much to do here that
i i do wonder about an analog of splice
in associations but i think it's not
relevant
well i i do think also that i mean it
might be too late now but it might have
been nice if that i mean i know it's i
think it's two deep prep values right
but um
i mean the
that case there with the nothing and the
value it might have been nice if that i
think it's not too late i think we could
investigate that
but also isn't it you can only have up
values like one level deep right so uh
yes
yeah
i mean that's been true for 35 years but
that might not stay true forever
um
i mean that awaits the rewrite of the
evaluator which i think actually does
values
if you look at the documentation for
values does it have like a second
argument or something you can wrap the
values in because otherwise if you say
values of that
of that association you're going to get
the bizarre
property that the keys will have a
different length from the values that is
really weird
look if values has some second obscure
second argument that's like oh you can
wrap the values in this head before
returning them
like hold
on
wrapping each of them of the head
right so if you try hold let's let's see
if that
that works
and i guess it doesn't have to be hold
it just be f but yeah okay still i
that's a little terrifying that you know
you could write some code that gets the
keys and gets the values and then tries
to map thread them and it freaks out
indeed that should definitely be
impossible issues
uh
i think
this goes impossible issues
okay
all right let's move on
groupings and unary functions
yes so this was discussed in
in tild and the thing here is that the
unary case is kind of singular for
groupings
and
we may not have right now the best
heuristics of what okay well so let me
understand what the issue is so the
issue is
that
if we say groupings
of
x y
comma
f arrow one
well that's too degenerate try g comma
two f comma one
g two f one
why was that first thing too degenerate
why was that i don't understand why that
was too degenerate well let's discuss
the heuristics this is using and then
you will understand that case i think
okay all right okay
um
so the question is that
we could put strings of f's and this
wouldn't change
of nested f's and and this wouldn't
change the
by the way if we don't have an example
with groupings with framed and as the
function we should add one
okay i love that
um okay
so what is the assume that you can have
f of f of f of f of f as deep as you
want right
exactly and because this is generating
trees with the number of with fixed
number of leaves two in this case
then we could have as many as we want
and so okay
this is i see so the main issue is
groupings is being sort of parameterized
by its leaf leaves by its number of
leaves now an interesting issue is what
leaf count does
on all of those things
oh how curious
what does that mean
why is the leaf count bigger
for those subsequent ones i wouldn't do
it with s instead of frames because
otherwise it's very hard to tell what's
going on
reused frames for both
what
oh
you mean what are you doing framed goes
to two frame goes to one
and you can visually see the nesting
can you
i would assume
well i wouldn't assume that because i i
would have thought what what even just
look at how deep oh frame framed in my
might
like
to do something for that
what
like phrase
yeah just do row and a list i don't know
yeah framed compose row or something
and list
does that really help i don't know
it helps in the depth actually but the
um
[Music]
not with the unary operators
the leaf count really should be two for
everything though
why is it four and five
i i don't understand how to leaf count
you can apply the unary operator
different numbers of times in different
groupings well that's the issue though
that's what we're talking about what i
would have expected is uniform leaf
count across all the inside no but the
heads it's counting the heads because
you can apply you know
for example if i had g of x y that has
you know
the leaf count is getting one from a
head but if i had
g of f of x comma y then now i have two
heads that are getting counted right
i think the clearest way to understand
this is is to use f and g and do three
four or or
first
right i mean it seems like the real
issue though is just that you know right
now
it's got g of f you know g of f of x
comma y and then it's got g of f of f of
x and it could keep going but it has
sort of arbitrarily decided to stop at
too right
right i don't understand i would have
expected that these things
the issue is we've got two genuine
leaves
right yes
and
but the leaf count of the expression
is the other parameter
and given
the genuine leaves and the leaf count
you determine
what set of trees you can get well the
thing is that in the first three we are
inserting one f in the others we are
inserting two f's i think that's why
this has nothing to do with the leaf
count right i mean the whole point is
you can add f's without affecting the
leaf count no no no you do affect the
these these leaf counts you're fine
that's not gross so stephen that is
that's not the default expression tree
if you do expression tree
comma atoms
then you'll see the leaf counts that are
showing up there
okay
and and by the way this is on a future
like this is a topic for a future lcc
meeting of if leaf count should take the
heads option
and if it did then you could say heads
goes to false and you would get two for
all exactly exactly
i think that will be very useful
i think that's a good idea and we could
just decide that it's a good idea now
because i don't think leaf can't takes
any options at all
um
okay either way i don't i don't really
see what leaf count how this solves the
problem of how many times you can best f
because because our non-genuine leaf
count
okay
in
is either four or five and if groupings
could have an argument which says
it could be any number it's just i know
i've truly been bounded at five yeah i i
know but i'm i'm saying
let's say that leaf that groupings could
take it up to n
for the for the our leaf count
well then i feel like if the idea is to
have an option like that then really
what it should be it should be the
maximum depth of f's
or it should be the maximum depth maybe
just the maximum depth of the
expressions because you could also have
two unary operators and you could have
any sort of combination of them
um
why do you think that's a better idea
than having the then bounding the
overall number of elements in the
expression
bounding the depth i think it's a less
arbitrary one
one argument is that leaf count
is
counting
things like rationals and complexes
as having multiple leaves within them
despite being atomic
like i i just don't think leaf count
should be tied to this
it's kind of i mean the actual the
actual leaf count function is wired i
mean like i think it's it's yeah i mean
that it is it is a low level thing that
does not reflect how you should think
about expressions i think but it also
should its documentation should be
updated and it should say for example
that it counts heads
and it should have a heads option
without without question it should have
a heads option
right but but so i mean with the the
trees here though the issue is that if
you had for example a leaf count bound
um or even a depth bound actually if
it's just like a bound over the whole
expression then the issue is that
it'll be very unclear if you set it too
low you're gonna be missing a bunch of
stuff and it'll be kind of weird and if
you set it too high then half the
results are just going to be f of f of f
of f of f when realistically you
probably just want a policy like the
current one where it's like oh just
apply f up to depth two what is the
current
one
the the current
policy is that
there will be a number of a maximum
number of f's equal to the number of
leaves it's it's a bit arbitrary but it
was easy to implement
it's just a way of bounding the number
of possibilities
of specified leaves exactly that's
totally arbitrary because it has nothing
to do with the number of leaves right
right so it's i agree it's totally
arbitrary but
it's difficult to choose with which one
is the right one
i mean you kind of maybe would like to
well
let me see
you you'd maybe like to have like a
okay so for every unarray operator you
have you'd like to have a number that's
basically how many
how many of this unary operator can you
have sort of uh
you know directly above you before
there's a non-unary opera what is this m
thing allows at most m sub i occurrences
in any given grouping of f sub i applied
to k sub i elements
what does that mean
is that not what we want here well but
that's not on the stack above it that's
just in the whole expression oh is it
i assume so
um let's just say one here
okay so that looks
the other kind of expression tree
because this is much harder to read i
think
thank you
okay so that appears to have only one f
altogether so let's say we have three
f's all together
oh that's rather nice
so the only issue is
possibly enhancing the m argument
the question is what is the default
value of m for a unitary operator
well it's not quite default value of m
though
right because in in the default behavior
there is no default value of m right now
i think it's just that
um
no the default value is infinity for m
exactly yeah
there is a global maximum and and the m
except the except that m is artificially
not infinity for unary operators because
otherwise the whole thing will blow up
right but that what i'm saying is that
it doesn't have a single value for unary
operator so i mean unit operators are
not bounded you know that's not the
mechanism by which they're bounded
right they're bounded by i mean
i i would kind of argue that the way
that you'd like to bound unary operators
is basically by saying
basically by saying you know you can
have you can have two f's kind of in a
in a in a row before there has to be
some non-unary operator
right it's like you could have uh you
know f of
g where g is not unary
you know of f f right that's okay you
know if you have two as the maximum
depth of f's you can have
right all right and that's relevant if f
is item potent for example or if f is um
you know
self-inverse
then you might very well want to you
know there might very well be cases
where you would where f of f of f of f
is irrelevant well yeah but also there
are cases where so for example if you
have two unary operators then you can
also have you know f of h of h of f of f
of h of h of f you know et cetera and
then i think again
why i think would probably be a
reasonable thing is just to say you know
in that whole chain of unitary operators
until you get to a non-unitary operator
there can only be
x you know some maximum number of f's
right
i see
that's an unclear case i mean if you're
mixing
two unary operators
right you can't just you can't just you
know go to infinity in that case no no
no so
uh
oh i didn't know there was that
orderless option that's really nice
drat i should have used that for a bunch
of things
um
is that really
consistent but we're trying to imitate
what our expressions would do if they
had an orderless attribute
no i understand but it's putting it oh f
arrow k commodoreless right
okay what are we gonna do here
um
so okay do we have proposals on the
table for what to do
um so brad had proposed um a possibility
which i interpret as you have all
groupings compatible with not having two
unitary operators together so who who
proposed this
oh badly yes
okay
what's that
we have brad here also
okay
hi
yeah so there is this example of um
of these complements there
showing the two so if you run that code
and the following lines
which one these up two compositions yes
that and then the example
where it compares the two results
so that that's showing what groupings
does that
brad's function does not vice versa
oh boy
sorry which one shows
so r1 is groupings and so you see how we
have two boxes together various times
so what he is doing is forbidding those
cases
i think i think that's the key point yes
which makes some sense
i mean
one might also
box could be not for example
and we may not want to track two boxes
if that unary operator is self-inverse
yeah i know
but the christopher case of multiple
unary operators is also questionable
like what would your thing do with
multiple unary operators
mine yeah can we try that you've got it
already does have multiple unary
operators it uses identity too
to do what
wait it has a square what's the other
unary operator here
oh i don't maybe do something other than
identity because identity's a bit hard
to uh you know yeah there we go
okay so wait there are some f of f of
x's
oh no sorry sorry that that f is around
the outer yeah never mind never mind
so how does it what's its policy on
you know f of square of x
or f of square of f of x
does it just never does it just never
apply unary operators on top of each
other
well the way that it works now is yeah
that's basically it it never implies
them on top of each other tries to apply
them one time only
at maximally through the
expression tree
okay so one possible parametrization
would be
a
maximum see it's not good enough to say
yeah one possibility is you're
sandwiching unary operators between
non-unary operators
this is your maximum sandwich amount
between
between two so there's also the case
where there are no non-unary operators
where you have like three unary
operators and nothing else
making sense
and what does it even do if you if you
do that and then you give it a list of
more than one
leaves does it just fail
you can't make a tree like that and if
you give it one leaf sorry if you give
it three leaves and then only unary
operators it cannot construct a tree
with three leaves only using unary
operators
but but it could do an outer product
over the unreal operators and the tree
leaves of some sort
okay that's not never going to work
right well yeah actually that's probably
a reasonable thing for her to do yeah
which thing which thing is a reasonable
thing they're returning an empty list
yes that's perfectly reasonable yes
that's the right thing so is this yeah i
mean and i think
in this case here
what if you have f and g yeah yeah
exactly or sorry what if get rid of the
second x just have f and g and one x
that is funko funko l'oreal
that's i think that's that's honestly
the most useful output it could give
yes but it's a little bit unexpected i
mean so why does that limit
when this is limited by it only used f
and g once each right exactly kind of
you know which i guess is because it's
the leaf count it's because it's the
number of of leaves you gave it
but if you gave it
yeah right so its current heuristic is
it uses the global count in the
expression
of the number of unary operators is
equal to the number of leaves
right
with a global count of how many times f
appears is equal to the number of leaves
right
which is which i suppose is so that f
can in principle go on every leave leaf
or it can move around the expression
or something
right but so that's one possible
parametrization to just specify a
maximum number of occurrences of each
given operator so for example we could
imagine
in that
look i don't understand
isn't this exactly the right thing this
m sub i here isn't that equivalent to
what you're presenting here
and the only question is what the
default is
right
so that's acting pair operator and the
question is what's the global
heuristics
hold on
also i would argue though that it might
be nice to instead of doing it but like
that to do it based on
you know the depth of the the operator
instead of a chain because otherwise you
know this this number is maybe could be
a bit too low
because if you make something like take
take you know here's a simple example i
mean this is like a super
you know this is probably kind of useful
application of groupings is something
like and or not and i would construct
all the different uh sort of uh
basically boolean circuits
um yes
exactly what brad was doing working on
something for me right and so and so
then the point is is that i want not to
be able to
to go on any you know not only do i want
to be able to have not on all the leaves
but i want to be able to have knot on
every leaf and i want to be able to have
it on every one of the higher
expressions too but if m is equal to the
number of leaves then there won't be
enough knots to go around right
yep
so
that's why i think that that
would be better if you just sort of said
something like oh you can never have
more than one knot in a chain of
of unary operators or you can never have
more than two knots and a chain of unity
operators or something like that
because at least then you know
you know
you could you could there are enough
knots to go around but you're never
going to have you know 25 knots all
applied in a row
okay so what you're saying is there's
unary icing that you could put on
everything it's basically what you're
saying
that unary is kind of free
so long as there's only one of it
you can you can
you can i don't know if it's one i mean
it could be more than one but yeah
right but the defaults will be how many
maybe one
right but i mean so what you're saying
is that if you have a unitary operator
in the mix
you get to add it as a piece of of you
know icing
on anything that you've got there
i i would say so i mean at least you
know as the default case at least
right but so that means you can decorate
you can you can put a unary
it's not a silly idea i mean that seems
quite sensible and quite explainable
that you can add the unary operator
to any you can add it just one sort of
uh dot of unity operator to any subpart
of the expression
but again the the the one caveat is if
you have two unary operators
by you can add it in one place you have
to make clear that it can only appear
sort of once in any chain of unary
operators
yeah otherwise you can just do fgf jfg i
understand so so what what has to happen
is that if there are multiple unary
operators the icing
is
you're basically doing
you know f comma g comma f of g comma g
of f
and any place that icing appears it can
only contain
you know some number of f's some number
of g's et cetera
and by default maybe that number is one
i think the only reasonable default is
one
yeah okay well i mean the question is if
it's it could be settable but maybe no
no it should
it might make the syntax i mean
groupings and syntax is already pretty
complicated it might make it even a bit
more convoluted to have a
thing for that but yeah well most m
occurrences in a given grouping
that's the that's the global m
and then this would be infinity comma i
mean probably the right form would be
um i mean do we care about this for
binary operators at all this this um
number of operator insertion or is it
irrelevant
i mean i would i was thinking it would
be of the well
i'm not sure what it would really mean i
mean for a binary operator what would it
mean
how many times can you use g
you know
in a chain of binary operators before
you reach a ternary operator or would it
just be how many i mean the more useful
one if you were going to have something
like this but this is different from the
unary case would be something like how
many g's can you have on the stack for
any given g is like how many g's how
deep can you be in g's but but i think
that's that's a different case and
you know
yeah right
so wait a minute brad is your function
equivalent to basically this kind of
thing
i tried to find output equivalent form
but i was unable to my first guess would
be that
you can
um go to groupings and
no no no i no no this is not a
capability that groupings has right now
this is this thing that we've just been
describing about icing
about using about thinking about
limiting
you know about saying you can add a
unary operator as icing anywhere and
when there are multiple unary operators
you do this kind of multi-icing type
thing i'm just asking is that equivalent
to what your
up to binary compositions thing does um
yeah it sounded reasonable to me and i
understood christopher's caveat
but i don't necessarily understand the
analogy to icing
because here's the thing
uh you never like make a cake i guess
and then just put on an infinite amount
of icing that that would be crazy
all right i mean this is a strategy of
to to to not you know to avoid the
infinite icing case
but no yes
what else can we describe it it's it's
um
well i just think of the the unary
operator thing in terms of
you know it's com it has no constraints
well but everything is
right but but everything else basically
has a counting constraint but yes right
but this is the whole point the question
is right now we have the question is do
we give it a global constraint or do we
give it a local constraint and what i
think is being argued is that it's
better to give it a local constraint of
how many times can it occur
in in there is a slot in which a unity
operator can occur there is a sub sub
expression that can be wrapped with a
unary operator
how many layers of wrapping paper to use
another analogy can we use
right
well i think that makes sense and i
think i also think um christopher's
caveat was important so we should make
note of that
so if i understand correctly the m i is
limiting the number of f's in a grouping
the new number would limit the number of
nested
right but i think it was
but i think at least my understanding is
it's it's not just nested but it's like
nested in a in a chain of unary
operators and i'm not sure if there's a
good analogy if there's a good you know
behavior for non-unary operators yeah
that's what i mean
yeah okay
i mean but there would be a separate
thing that might also be useful but is a
totally different thing which is
you know
um
you know
which could work for non-urinary
operators is just basically restricting
how deep you can have you know if
they're already three g's on the stack
you can't add another one right
yes
stack depth
yeah that's a different thing though
i noticed nick is here there's
actually there are two necks the nick
without a c
um the do you have any comments on this
actually either nick but um
go ahead
i have
the idea that the global counter is kind
of better dude for
at least for campinator extra but yeah
having both is definitely beneficial
that's the only comment i can give you
you're arguing that that should we
should not get rid of the global counter
no no no
yeah well i agree i mean i don't i don't
think we can i mean i think that that
that one for sure
right but so the issue is
that the default becomes instead of okay
so let me suggest
this is the defaults then
and there could be some bizarre version
of the current behavior by doing this
for example
although i consider the current behavior
less than optimal
by the way
in removing the current behavior
so again
we can get rid of the current behavior
it's it's not that somebody should check
a bunch of my posts because i'm pretty
sure these are used in click to copy
code because i don't think i was really
aware of this issue and i think i've
used it to generate
boolean expressions for example
and arguably done the wrong thing that
way but that's different issue
um
but i was gonna ask um is there
should it be should it be should the
infinity column automatically in a list
as opposed to not in a list
yeah i i don't know
well
i was thinking the same thing that we
could have a third element there
i mean having a list does make it kind i
mean it's already very nested by the
time you get already having another
level of list
okay
now
okay can we just talk for a minute about
stack depth about things on the stack
um
let me that's the fourth argument
well the thing we don't have which i
think we might consider
is random groupings
possibly
i mean
back in times of snp i had this function
called rex
the random expression generator which
rears its head every so often
um which was essentially a markov chain
random expression generator otherwise
known as random groupings
would random actually
i i would guess that the better way of
doing that i mean we have a similar
thing with like subsets right where
where you know there's no there's no ren
actually maybe there isn't a random
subset there's a function repository
random subset or something
but um but but if you want to do it you
know in the top level what you do is you
do you can compute the number of subsets
you know without too much difficulty and
then you just do subsets and then you
use its second argument where you can
select which subset do you want
so i it kind of seems like the thing
would be if somehow if you could if you
would one if it were easy to get the
number of possible groupings because
unlike substances i think that's not as
trivial a calculation and two if you
know if you could get the uh
if you could ask for a particular index
i think because it's so difficult to ask
for the particular index
of groupings i mean yeah it's true i
mean getting the number of groupings is
painful enough that
look we've had this issue in a number of
cases we have it for cellular automata
also how many cellular automata are
there that are totalistic with their
neighbors blah blah blah
um
and you know we have considered having a
function that will answer questions like
that
like a single function that answers all
those questions i don't know if that
makes any sense
i don't know if that makes any sense
no i mean it seems crazy i mean look
we've got a separate function for the
number of groups of a given size and
things like this
um for simple cases of functions of
single functions of given unary we can
do it via random tree so first
first creating the
skeleton and then placing the leaves but
for the general case of multiple
functions of given units
getting a tree with the right
distribution of probability
is probably quite difficult but why is
this
how can you specify on random tree how
many binary
no
we just can't say um
the number of notes
right so you can't say i mean you might
be able to say give me a random binary
tree
yes so then
i think if if we have a single
uh um adity then it might be doable
but the other possibility is that we
could have
a groupings look
like a tree distribution
yeah something like that what i'm
imagining is i mean i could imagine here
random tree of n arrow k
giving you a k erie
tree with n nodes and k
where instead of this k
a a random tree of n arrow k
you know something like that
being a random tree with this seems
useful actually yeah that could be nice
yes we had already planned to generalize
the the first argument to varieties of
of trees
it's always difficult to find
the the the generation method that
guarantees um
uniformity
well i mean what i was thinking is what
i was about to say is why not give a
grouping specification in the random
tree
see but the thing is random tree has a
different that number there is something
not accessible to groupings that number
is the total you know
tree element count
for the groupings
it's size versus leaf count
yeah
oh yeah because right this is not right
this is a different number and also i
think you know random tree returns a
tree not expression so
it's
you know if you want a mechanism for
returning random groupings i don't think
that's really the best way to do it but
the thing we don't have
in
groupings is something
yeah usually it is deterministic without
the unary stuff
it's completely deterministic how big
the trees are going to be given just the
number of leaves
correct yeah yes
that's even true if you have different
areas of operators
well it'll change if you have different
areas of operators but
you know what it means
if i say groupings
um if you have 10 if you have 10 leaves
and you have a single tenory operator
then there's only one grouping you can
do
right right but but if you have a you
know a binary operator then again
there's there's a
there's a you're bounded by the whatever
it is the log base 2 of 10 or something
like that floor of log base 2 10 for the
depth
so the modulo order this this answer is
uniquely defined
it's it's a unary case and each one
okay i'm confused by this just do a leaf
do do whatever it's called length of
tree leaves of
tree expression tree of those well
alternatively i could just do level
i just do how many symbols are in here
if i just say level
of hash minus one
heads goes to true
why why you want heads
uh
well they all have the heads if you're
trying to count the size
yeah i don't want them if you're trying
oh you're trying to count the size okay
yeah
okay so what's happened here
i am so freaking confused here okay so
there are three f's
i think it's because you have
um
different audits there are like
different partitions yes right
right
by the way we should talk about this in
the groupings
possible issues section things that the
leaf count is not constant
well the leaf count as measured by the
leaf count function but that is not if
you ask me what the the the leaf count
you know the true leaf kind of these
expressions is then it is constant
yeah
that is a bit unfortunate the leaf count
is not counting what we would now
consider to be leaves i mean it just
does a little thing also if the first
argument is a list of things other than
atoms
then you're just doomed because leaf
counts gonna be counting the leaf counts
of those
from the point of view of groupings
right
yeah okay
but i'm still arguing that there might
be a case where having the actual number
of atoms
bounded would be useful but i'm not sure
but but okay but back to random trees do
we imagine that there are many tree
distributions that we will include in
random tree
are we are we expecting that we will
have as a whole zoo of tree
distributions as we do for things like
graph distributions
yeah probably there are cases like do
you count
reordering of the labels
yes yes yes yes i can see that but so do
we actually have a a
project have you talked to the
statistics team
about this
ian
no
maybe you should because i think i think
it will be good to
they seem to like doing these giant
literature surveys of all distributions
of a given kind
um
right because i mean what what we're
saying is
you know what we'll need is things like
this right
yes a parametrization of possibilities
right
but but whether we want to introduce
such a random tree something i mean do
you know the algorithm for doing nra
trees
what do you mean for just uniform
uniform distribution of energy
yes i think it should be straightforward
like
the algorithm i'm using basically views
our general trees as binary trees
like the first and then the rest
there's like an isomorphism between
binary trees and plane trees
okay
didn't don know
send us a piece of code that we put in
the function repository for doing this
that was four what are called free trees
they don't have a root
ah
okay
um yet another
tree distribution we could have
sounds to me like we're going to need a
bunch of tree distributions
um
so you should we should make sure that's
a project and
uh please talk to the people who did the
graph distributions
i think makes sense ian
yep
okay so
possibility of doing this but we're not
sure maybe you should look into tree
distributions first
with respect to this i think what we're
concluding is
that we are going to use the wrapping
paper layers like aka the icings method
we should have it as three arguments
here wherever we had that
um the
uh frok comma
um
because we're decorating the k
with things like orderless
right this case here
okay
so this will be infinity comma one will
be the default
which is a change
which is a little bit scary that we're
making that change
a little bit scary
and we could have infinity comma
automatic be the default
let's see what we break
good test cases do we break a bunch of
stuff i've done for example do we break
test cases and so on by making that
change
fallback is we make the default be
infinity comma automatic as it is right
now and we have infinity comma one be
just a documented thing you can do
instead
and and for the case where
k
here is not equal to one
the last argument will do what
will it be an error or will it do
nothing or will it well do something
i would propose that for now we make an
error
i don't know i would have to implement
this first and see
i cannot predict sometimes
okay but i my my initial take would be
if k is not equal to one
the fourth argument should not be
allowed
the fourth element should not be allowed
okay comments from anybody else anybody
nope okay
good
all right that was that
shuffles
yeah so there were a handful of popular
shuffling algorithms in the function
repository that are deterministic and
the general question was
does it make sense to have a shuffling
function that potentially has methods
uh you know a a i have no opinion i've
not used have never used shuffles
anybody got an opinion about this
danny or rick that would well
yeah they could be used in i suppose
experimental designs
where you
do want some kind of
ordering perhaps
other than that
it i mean random sample will give you
a
you know a random ordering right
right i i'm thinking there might be
situations particularly in the context
of experimental design where you don't
want it to be random
but you want to be able to change it in
a
specific way and that these shuffles
might provide that
is there a parametrization of shuffles i
mean i don't know what the difference
between in shuffle and out shuffle is
i don't remember um but these are
standard terms we checked that
right but the question would be if there
is
a number
this is an ed peg kind of question this
this is i mean
because
given a list
in which some elements are identical
there is a numbering is there not maybe
brad knows this i don't know
um there is a numbering
uh unique numbering for
possible orderings is there not
no it's given permutations right you can
clearly you can specify it's trivial to
specify
you know a number between you know one
and n factorial for the
that specifies a permutation if none of
the elements are identical if some
elements are identical it gets more
difficult
i'm thinking that perhaps we could
consider this like a named permutation
and put it in permute the second
argument of permute
i think that's an interesting idea
yeah
because permute takes a permutation
or a group collection
and so we could just say
this is a named permutation i think
that's a good idea
that seems like a good idea to me okay
yeah i mean that way it's at least
accessible and
it's within an existing framework so i
think that when i looked at it there are
only
roughly these three deterministic
shuffling systems so going with permute
makes a lot of sense
fine does it relate at all to find
permutation as well
um
well
that would be the inverse function
taking two lists and returning all right
i'm just wondering if if it can you know
yeah right i mean
yeah it would be a bit strange to return
a string instead instead of a yeah
that'd be a good function repository
thing
but it's cycled i just because i don't
yeah i mean the cycles you can always
find the permutation group and the
cycles you can get that for any group
right so you can always return cycles
yeah cycles is a problem
it's something that maps the cycles to
the names would be good in the function
repository i think
but how do you get from the cycles how
do you get the actual permutation
experimentation list
oh i see so could i do that for
maybe you should be able to say
can you say permutation list of
well
no yeah i mean there's there's can you
say permutation list of of you know
for the second because it takes a length
so the second
line could be generalized to take a
string
return the permutation and understand
so cycle syslab is a bit like the sparse
representation of a permutation right
and so
permutations are oh i see what you're
saying i see what you're saying you're
saying i could just have cycles one two
but my whole permutation could be of
length to ten
exactly
so i see so it's like digit it's like in
in from digits
yes or when you say i have a sparse
array with element two but the this part
the the vector has length seven
it's two lists in cycles
so it's a list of lists two levels of
lists
right i guess then the next and the next
logical question is can you have mongian
shuffle inside of permutation group
no i think that would be a bit too much
yeah okay fine
okay but so so the concept would be
i'm sorry if you really wanted that
you'd probably want to do
permutation list of your mongian shuffle
until at the length and then
there's a function that gets you the
cycles from the permutation list right
here
is saying look at applications and
properties
okay
that's
i see that's got a number of account the
number of shuffles to do
so that would be a nest of a permute
it's a permutation power
yes
oh can we do we have a permutation power
function yep
so you're saying that the permutation
power
boy this is this is um
but but this wouldn't work because if
you say in shuffle or something it has
no idea how long that shuffle is right
we would have to go first through the
conversion to permutation list and then
there
yeah which i think is fine
i mean the only only thing is it becomes
a little bit you know
i don't know maybe this like there's
some line and the details and options of
some documentation page that kind of
makes it clear like
you know because because right now it's
sort of it's sort of implicit like what
how do you define a permutation is it
cycles or is it permutation list
and understand making it so that
sorry sanders function is very nicely
done here
good work this is very nice
oh this is interesting as well the idf
permute is just to avoid the
introduction of a new symbol but
if if it's usable we can have the symbol
itself
yeah i think it's i think it seems nice
especially because i mean
i think it's also nice to have things
like permutation list
work but i mean it's just that i i'm
just thinking about like uh
i mean permute
nominally permute takes you know a
permutation specification as its first
argument and there are several other
functions that also take permutation
specifications and so we should at least
make maybe make it clear that like okay
well maybe permutation and permutation
list will take this thing but but this
isn't really a full-fledged permutation
specification that like permutation
group will accept you know i mean the
thing that is a little bit complicated
for me is that you know santa has done
very nice job here
in
these function repository functions
and the question is at what point is it
worth making system functions out of
these things
and to what extent i mean because there
is a there are certain kinds of things
which are definitely going to be too
specialized for us to want to make
system functions out of them so it is
unclear to me what the policy should be
in this case
you mean because you know if you just
think that the function repository
function is so beautiful and it's kind
of specialized you know just let it be
that's that's what i'm wondering i mean
i'm wondering whether that
you know
it's
you know whether it's easier to find it
in the function repository than it is to
find it as a
uh sort of a sideshow of permute for
example
there's no reason it can't be both
no there's absolutely no reason it can't
be both and it's certainly we we are
just adding the people on the livestream
are asking about this we are just now
adding i don't know if any of them are
live yet links from uh function
reference pages
to function repository pages
um it's a little bit we're doing it a
little bit gingerly because
you know
the the function repository things in
general are not as
robust general
permanently designed etc
but um you know it's certainly useful to
be able to do that although there are
things which will appear in the function
repository that we never expect to
appear in the system because they're
just quite specialized and quite you
know a particular tower of corresponding
to a particular workflow that's fairly
specific
um
i'm confused by this one what to do with
this
one anybody got any thoughts about this
i mean i i think that the idea of
inserting in a bermuda is interesting
and maybe we do that
with the notion that
many people will just use it from the
function repository
i don't know anybody got further
opinions and i'm a little bit concerned
about the creep of does it work in
permutation power type thing
yeah that's a good point perhaps we
should just link from permute to these
functions and the users would find them
immediately
i think that's the place to start
let's do that yeah we'll do that
provisionally and if there's a strong
case to revisit it we can
do that
all right just couple minutes here on
these let's take a look
isn't replace at
part of a
potentially giant family
that will be
in this multi-replace business
do we want replace that
or is it
sorry i don't really understand how is
this function different from just the
level of stack of replace is it just
that you can tell it to replace
or or map is giving it
applies the rules at those positions
but so it's the same thing as map at of
the operator form of the place right
yes yeah but that doesn't do what you
want if it's like held code for example
oh or wait let me think about it yeah i
mean it's very similar to what you just
said map at what's operate with an
operator form of replace
wait what what is the hell the hell
what what
is there a simple held code case just to
understand it or
so if we were to
map
replace across
you know something that's held like hold
of one two and three and the replacement
is just adding one to each of those
things
oh sure end up with held replacement
sure yes yeah sure
what are you saying hold one two three
here yeah
right if you met the point is the
replace won't run it'll just sit yeah
by the way nick was emphasizing to me
the fact that this is incredibly close
to having you know we we've talked for a
long time about the merger of patterns
and
uh and function functions
and of course this is incredibly close
to that
say merger or murder
merger
okay
good to clear that up
yes
um
right i mean
it's yeah because it's very unclear what
i mean it is interesting that replace is
just incredibly close to just doing
uh
i mean if i'm if
i don't know what the only difference
might be the fall through case but
admittedly you know but down values when
they fall through they also just don't
evaluate so
function never doesn't evaluate
it's an untyped lambda
it just eats whatever well having said
that
it largely eats whatever you can give it
the wrong number of arguments you can
give it the wrong number of arguments in
which case
it um
uh
and i guess we don't have
here's a question do we have a mechanism
okay so
really
i didn't know is that obvious that it
has to do that
did that surprise anybody that it did
that
a bit yeah
well there's a complicated case of
if you have a function
like if you're using slot like if you
don't so so you basically don't specify
the number of inputs
and then
you know and then you give it ten
arguments
that's why it has to do this
um
there's a question about function
about but there is no way to specify in
a function
and there probably and there shouldn't
be right a curried version of this
that
yes i think so
that would be curry applied
is that right that it will it will just
do the right thing here
curry applied of that function
uv
oh come on you're missing some brackets
after the function needed an open
bracket oh
don't you need to tell curry applied how
many arguments
oh it needs an operator form of applied
of curry applied you need to close off
the u or something like that
oh no telling it the number okay
but you need to tell it that it takes
two yeah
curry applied
function comma two of u of v
yes right so
you can add the the two after function
well that will work as well because
that's right
that's absurdly worried but yes
um
okay
okay but anyway so
the
so the point is you're saying map at of
replace
is equivalent to replace that
correct
it's not equivalent in the case where
there's healthy stuff
except for edge cases
is replaced that interesting
i use
this all the time i'd say more
convenient than interesting
okay well that's yeah if you don't have
it what do you have to do to make it
i mean other than the you know other
than the cases where you can do a map
out of replace
and why is it
okay replace part
is something where you don't know the
parts you'd have to get the positions to
make the to find the parts but here you
could have replace at a whole list of
possible replacements and then the
candidate parts to put them at
that seems useful
let's go ahead and try and make this one
okay sounds good
oh
this is another in the category of
there's a matrix of functions
yeah i mean a lot of these probably
aren't that interesting um
but there are lots of permutations of
take that there isn't a corresponding
drop and
there are some wild variants that might
be interesting to look at
yeah i mean i think this is a
it's very useful these these matrices
are very very useful but they're also
kind of terrifying because it's like you
know
you know by adding length while did we
just sign up to make a length largest
and stuff like that
we don't need these i mean this is the
point this is like it's like natural
language we should learn something from
natural language like natural language
as you can tell by looking at an english
grammar book does not have these
matrices
if you look at latin grammar book it has
a lot of matrices but but well they do i
mean there are like some holes there
usually are some holes so yeah right but
that's the point is that when our matrix
like this comes along this is what makes
you think
maybe we could have some inflection like
like the meta map
stuff that we were talking about you
know last week now that's an inflection
right but yeah
but at the same time yeah maybe in a
somewhat latin-like way it can become
very unwieldy if you know when you want
to do map indexed it's you know some
weird
and you know triple inflected form of
map
yes well that which is why in natural
language things get shortened
and you know why the verb to be is
usually totally weird in most languages
um
all right we should wrap up here
i
i
was getting dropped
i don't know i'm not sure we we should
look at it another time i'm just i'm
just kind of
sampling these what the heck is discard
i think drop while i don't know i'm
unsympathetic to these functions where
it's a questionable value and then also
it's easy to implement yourself
and it seems like you can just do you
know reverse of take while a reverse
right
this
discard
why can't you just do not there yeah it
is it's literally just
an inverted select um but
well
it's just the
i mean this has come up over off and on
over the years
you know we have cases and delete cases
but we don't have the d version of
select
i mean it is a common idiom but it's
just sort of like it's so easy to write
not at star
yeah
yes i think so i think we
we kind of thought it was common enough
but um certainly willing to be argued
out of that
i think it was useful before we had
composition but now it doesn't seem
all that needed
right
although
yeah we should make sure that the select
page has on it not at start examples
that's um sounds like a good action item
um
okay two comments on our live stream
then we should wrap here um edmund says
couldn't all these drop while be done by
a drop by and a while buy where the user
gives the function
drop by
yeah that's something you tell people
casually you want to see them later
the drop by function
yeah
drop by danny's place
no but i i'm trying to understand what
would that actually do so
i mean the buy functions i would say
things like sort by have been
tremendously successful
[Music]
what would drop by so drop by
would be something
it would trim the first elements that
match that condition
maybe
i'm not sure
it it's
it it really is too different from drop
i think
i mean
placement where where not
i agree the drop is a very cool so
again it's one of these things though
where it's like
it's it's
i think adding a super kind of
funky
not super readable
form that lets you do this isn't very
useful because you can also just write
it yourself using
take by or to take while and reverse and
et cetera et cetera
right i agree with that
yeah by the way something we should do
and we should wrap them just a moment
here but but
some of these things like
sort by sort by has been very successful
you know take largest buy has been very
successful
some of these other things we've
introduced have been in my to my mind
less successful like some of the fold
pair list stuff
um
which
you know and and i guess the question is
for us to
reflect a bit on what's been successful
and why
i mean to me
the whole i mean operator applied i
think has been
reasonably successful
uh certainly i've used reverse supply
plenty of times
people been using operator applied
that's a deafening silence
i haven't really used any of the applied
functions just because
probably because i i haven't i haven't
used them so i don't really understand
which does what
and they're all sort of subtly different
right
well and also the fact that often
they're a bit longer than if you just
write it as a pure function
yes i mean look i am slowly getting more
used to using at star
and um i still get a little bit confused
by the precedence of some of those
things
um
and uh anyway
all right well we should wrap up here
i'm actually doing another live stream
in just a moment here um on a quite
different topic but
thanks to folks here and thanks to folks
on the live stream see